um I suppose I should uh go on to um the
hentai that I recommended okay uh which
is a little bit of a curveball because I
got uh the category name something
that's awoke something in you so I sure
I took that as a hentai that has a
pretty like something I wouldn't usually
watch but then I watched it and I was
like I don't know why I kind of [__]
with that
um so do you want to explain the basic
premise of the show yeah I'm trying I'm
trying to get the name again I think
it's I think it's called
yeah yeah so
um which means uh semen collection
Hospital oh what is the word for semen
again
yes
you learn something new every day yeah
okay that's cool so another word to not
remember yeah so I'd say this this is a
simple pretty easy premise you know you
you have a guy who has this weird ass
medical disc Condition it's this
weird-ass medical condition they didn't
really this is the average Twitter user
yeah do you want to use that so like so
like you know you know okay I'm gonna
you know in speed people have seen speed
where there's this bus right but uh if
if this bus goes below 50 miles an hour
the bus will explode yeah so imagine
that with a guy's dick okay so it
doesn't jerk off every three hours yeah
yeah his balls literally explode so so I
don't know why I don't know if this
probably is not I really hope this isn't
a real medical condition no of course it
is not done of course it is not real uh
but yeah this guy is a medical condition
where if he doesn't if he doesn't
ejaculate every three or so hours the
then his nuts will explode just
literally just like and I assume like
the hospital will explode with him I
don't know I don't know if the severity
of the explosion yeah yeah he'll
probably just die and you might be
thinking to yourself well that's an easy
solution yeah you can just jack off
every three hours yeah no no they've
figured out that plot Hole by breaking
both of his hands yeah he's in this
hospital and agent has no hands yeah he
has a he has nuts that are about to
explode and two broken casting hands so
he can't do anything yeah and the closer
he gets to the three hours the more
searing pain his nuts are in yeah so
it's it's it's kind of like it's like
kind of like a ticking time it's whiny
the whole time yeah he was a [__] he
was a little [__] yeah yeah but uh so
the main premise of this is of course he
has he has to get the nurses to uh to
take care of this condition for him sure
and we've seen some variations of this
hentai before I feel you know you you
have like a nurse whose job it is to
take care of a medical position and then
oh they get a get a little frisky the
nurse starts liking him maybe but no
this one the nurse hates the job she
hates him and you think okay maybe in
the end maybe and then she starts
enjoying it she starts like turning
around maybe like she sees a side of the
guy that she starts like no she hates
him from beginning to end and she is not
afraid to say how disgusting this
[__] boy is yeah and I was just like
I I got it I I saw this and I was I
remember I remember watching this I was
waiting for the turn you know I was
waiting for I was waiting for like the
emotional turn that we've seen with the
girl yeah and it's like it just never
happens yeah so this main girl just has
to basically make him
poor nurse you're not getting paid
nearly enough yeah that's to make him
ejaculate yeah so yeah so again like
this was another one where I was
initially confused right and I'm still a
bit confused where I watched all three
episodes by the way oh really I only
really liked the first one yeah yeah
because I I watched the first episode
and I was waiting for the turn and I was
like oh this is the thing that made
something awoke in God and I was and all
I thought at the end of episode one was
are you okay guys no no no no no no I I
kind of get it I don't get it at all I
get it really I'm gonna speak for gone
here
I don't know what it is I don't know if
gone has this too all right there is
something kind of attractive about how
she doesn't want to do it yeah really I
don't know why it's the disguster which
she she shows is kinda attractive I
don't know why I don't thank you
someone's I was afraid I was afraid I
was gonna get clowned up but like
something about just the disgust and not
having the turn I was like I don't know
what and again in real real life I would
absolutely despise this because in real
life I I just it's gross yeah I think
it's viable because like you know if
they don't like me I'm not into it in
real life yeah in the show of the way
it's portrayed I can understand again I
wouldn't jack off to it but I I
understand that you would find that
attractive oh I am the complete opposite
of that yeah like I I watch this and I'm
like wow this what a [__]
okay I'm like everyone in the show's a
[__] you didn't watch episode 203 did
you no okay she was actually the nicest
because at the end of episode one when
she leaves she's like you know I'm
actually one of the few nurses that's
quite tolerable and I'm like yeah it
gets worse oh it gets worse dude it like
opens up right and she's like oh fine so
she like Jacks him off and it's like
okay cool yeah scene ends yeah and he's
like oh I need a pee I can't pee and
then it's so pathetic and then he's like
I'm done peeing and she like goes the
toilet and holds his PB up he's not
helping people he's like but I wanna I
wanna I wanna come I want to know oh my
God fine and she's like you're
disgusting you're disgusting whatever
yeah he goes like [__] everywhere and
then later on for some reason I don't
know why that it kind of escalates and
then she is willing to do it with her
mouth I don't know why no no it's
because he's like I've jacked off so
much in my life yeah that I need
something stronger yeah I need more
sensation I need to level up and she's
just like [__] you and he's literally
Beggars cannot be choosers bro you do
not get the desire yeah yeah yeah and
yeah I I don't know just like there is
like there's like a there's like a kind
of like dojin series which is like uh
that this really really reminds me of is
it the the panties one yeah like I
should like I can't remember the full
name but it's just like I make a
disgusted face while I show you my
panties or something like that and
normally it's just like a series of
images but this perfectly this is the
one this is the only hentai I've seen
that has perfectly captured the energy
of this one dozen Series where yeah and
it's became an anime right yeah it did
become yeah yeah and the whole premise
of this anime is that uh for some reason
uh the girls have to sh it's like it's
actually like a prv it's a POV anime so
it's done so it's almost like you are
talking to this girl and you're trying
to convince this girl to show you uh to
show her her panties to you right uh and
then the premise is you convince her to
do it she shows it and she's just
disgusted at you she hates it yeah and I
feel like this this for some reason this
hentai the this one episode the entire
episode is just I feel like it's based
it must be based on this Dojo I thought
I thought for a split second because I
also thought up of that show as well
because it definitely gave off the same
Vibes and I'm like is there a
possibility that it's done by the same
author yeah and I looked it up and it
wasn't but I was like it must have been
like I guess this is like a genre that I
never knew about and that people are
into and I'm like all right who's also
insanely well animated it was like it
was like there's a show I'll give it
that yeah they do it and then she like
cleans herself out and it's insanely
well animated for some reason yeah I
don't know why but also there's a scene
in this that happens about halfway
through where the nurse is kind of
talking [__] about having to do this
yeah and he's outside listening and then
he walks in he's like hey why are you
saying bad things about me you know well
you don't like doing it and he's she's
like I literally have told you every
single time I [__] hate you and it's
like what do you want from her yeah she
is a nurse who has to jack you off
no I think he said he was like I I don't
feel good because uh you don't feel good
about doing this and I'm like [__] [__]
you dude
you're like bro this is your Affliction
yeah she is not getting paid enough to
do this yeah she just does not want to
do this I imagine she's a medical
professional who knows apparently become
a pseudo prostitute because your dick
don't work yeah I I think that's why I
think that's kind of why this works I
feel like this would I feel like this
would have worked less if she was just
like a [__] yeah it would have been uh
just annoying yeah if she was just a
[__] to someone who was just not doing
anything wrong yeah but I was like
looking at this guy seeing this [__]
beta being like
this isn't enough can you like give me
more yeah it's like bro what are yours
yeah it's like bro come on and like her
just being like I hate you you are
disgusting you are a pathetic worm and
I'm just like I don't know I don't
disagree yeah I don't disagree I'll do
that I'll give it that like because the
guy was such a [__] boy like I I felt
for the girl and it made it be like yeah
girl [__] don't take [__] from this
guy but like maybe maybe I should
empathize more with the guy with a three
sensitive enough to come with you like
jacking me off I don't like bro come on
come on you're like I'm hungry and you
get food and they're like actually could
I have a crown it's like it's like it's
like what it's like what did you want
did you want me to go to the MILF Manor
and get the spray like exactly right
yeah no but but I think like I I get
that I completely get like you know
because of the fact that the guy was
such a little [__] right yeah where
it's like okay yeah this girl has every
right to be mean as [__] to the guy yeah
it was hot yeah but like hot take I like
my hentai where the women like it
here's the thing here's the thing okay
here's the thing I I agree with you I I
normally agree I normally agree yeah
um because you know normally if the girl
doesn't like it
um then it's [__] NTR or something
right it's just like the complete
opposite of course I feel this was
closer to just emotionless sex right
yeah yeah yeah yeah this this I I
normally
I guess because like even emotionalist
sex like it's not as because there was
an emotion it's not quite in fact there
was a lot of emotion in this it's just
the complete opposite of emotion of it
was what I got into it it was disgusting
yeah which I don't really like in any
context personally yeah no I I get back
um I was surprised that I found it hard
because I was just like I ain't really
like into that kind of stuff in real
life I hate that [__] yeah yeah I was
like it's like to me I'm like I want to
stay away from that stuff I want a girl
to be like in it with me and I want to
have a good time together which is why
you know I chose this hentai for this
one category because it's the only
hentai I've seen that has fully
committed fully fully committed to just
the girl being disgusted okay and so
episode two and three yeah it follows
the same guy ah yeah it follows the same
guy little [__] baby but like the girls
just get progressively more sadistic
yeah yeah how does it get wow
the kind of I guess one of the first
things is that you know they obviously
uh somebody just gets transferred and I
was curious to see how to get worse so
that's why I can't even watching yeah
and there's a girl who's clearly like a
bit evil she's laughing at him calling
him like a loser and [__] yeah and then
she deserves she uh
Jacks him off and then uh she takes a
video of her doing it and she's like oh
if you don't if you don't start
appreciating it I'm gonna post this
everywhere oh [__] so in six hours you
better start groveling to me yeah uh and
he's like what are you what why
I just say like Morty's voice every time
and then so she comes back and he's like
oh I I know I don't think I appreciate
it I just need to I just need to come
and then she's like all right fine so
she jacks him off and then puts the that
the excrement in the uh in his food and
then starts feeding it to him but then
he doesn't want to eat it and then she's
like all right well if you eat me you
can eat the food and so she starts
pouring it it's gross it's so nasty yeah
I'm good dog uh and then it kind of gets
worse and there's one point that it
really made me laugh it was he kept
going like I want the old nurse back I
want a bag she was cool I feel so dumb
and she's like oh you want a bang oh you
want a bag fine and then she he takes
time he takes him to her locker and she
makes him she's like jacking him off and
she's like you better you better not all
over her clothes I don't know why he
[__] like like a [__] turret like
machine gun she's like
reload yeah and then the nurse comes up
she's like bro what the [__] and then
he's like haha and then she starts
jacking him off on her she's like bro
what the [__] collateral yeah and it's
just like what the [__] is this it's so
[__] dumb but it keeps getting more
sadistic and then yeah yeah and then the
third nurse goes into like electroshock
there electroshock therapy yeah and it
goes down that route so it just gets it
at like it gets closer and closer just
like yeah yeah she puts a a flashlight
on a power drill and then oh yeah just
turns it and then turns it on on this
and he's just and it's just like it's
like it's like a cotton candy machine of
nuts it's just going you know cotton
candy comes out like imagine that bit of
a flashlight just going everywhere it's
it's it's like a band moist critical
Contraption
Charlie is like nah this is going too
far
[Music]
honestly like it's it was that third
like because it like like I said I'm not
really into this kind of stuff but the
first episode had that perfect balance
you know what you know yeah you know why
it's right because when she said I'm one
of the good nurses yeah I I believed it
yeah
I was like you know what she has taken
care of yeah maybe she didn't appreciate
as much she wanted but I think she did a
job yeah I didn't talk to you I think
she could didn't you didn't honestly
above and beyond honestly honestly she
did the fact that she like she did every
request that he asked even though he was
a little beautiful [__] baby
boy yeah absolute her before he's he's
the herbivore that gets eaten by her
before like holy [__] and she put up
with that [__] and she just did her job
she was a professional from start to
finish yeah okay did she verbalize her
did she leave she's a little harsh yeah
did she what did she verbalize her
thoughts of course she's definitely
underpaid okay maybe maybe then episode
one will awake me if I watch episode two
and three and I look back at it
retrospectively and being like a
retrospective boner yeah and I'm like
you know what now I think about it yeah
that's all right you know and you know
what if there are any other anime that
even like closely resemble how like how
balanced this first episode is kind of
interested because I don't know I'm like
I thought it was really well done yeah I
thought it was really well done piques
my interest and I'm like can't really
think of any other hand like this Japan
is really good at doing that and then
just [__] it all off by the way oh
yeah just ruining it yeah yeah yeah but
yeah that's that's that one I definitely
worth a watch yeah uh I think I think
this was look like one episode yeah I
think I think the episode first episode
is worth the watch second and third
episode
it goes it loses that balance